this is it castle rockers the preview
for the last episode of the season so if
you haven't seen it yet I've left a link
in the description then come on back the
first 10 seconds is footage we've seen
before mixed with some interesting
editing that might be hard to miss
Molly's seen here in episode 5 or counts
tragic Castle Rock events including Alan
pangborn's death that didn't happen
until episode 7 but this is probably
just the editing she also mentions the
fire at juniper Hill but the
corresponding image seen here is of the
hospital where young Henry was sent to
in the alternate timeline unless of
course that hospital is juniper Hill in
the alternate timeline the kid says as
long as I'm here people will die I can't
stop it
as were shown an aerial shot of an
explosion in downtown castle rock
followed by Henry and the kid locked up
across from one another interesting
considering how much these two have
spent in cages remember that Henry ran
from the police and episode 8 after the
murder of Gordon and his wife and the
kid is the prime suspect of the Juniper
hill fire were then given a series of
quick flashes mixing some old and new
footage the new stuff shows Ruth looking
contemplative remember that she was last
seen by Reverend Appleton in episode 8
acting confused this is what sparked
Henry to run away from the police molly
holds one of the soap carvings possibly
the one the kid left on her diorama in
episode 5 wendell in the forest here
leads me to believe he'll cross
timelines remember in episode 8 he
started to hear the skismo and we know
how it draws people into the forest we
then get two shots of young Henry
watching someone or something go over
the bluffs at Castle Lake this is likely
his father Mathew Deaver who you recall
from episode 1 foul and broke his back
and finally the preview ends with the
kid answering Henry's question of who
are you by saying the same as you before
we see Henry pointing a gun at an
unknown figure I don't know about you
guys but I am pumped for this episode
I'll be coming out with my full
breakdown this Thursday so make sure
you're subscribed until then